[Music]
good evening the house has voted to
impeach president trump for a second
time in 13 months
now unlike the first impeachment this
time 10 republicans joined with
democrats
thanks for joining us at five i'm denise
valdez
good evening i'm brian loftis now this
all comes exactly
one week after the violent assault on
the capitol building
where ultimately five people died
president trump released this video just
a couple of hours ago
i unequivocally condemned the violence
that we saw last week now i am asking
everyone who has
ever believed in our agenda to be
thinking of ways to ease tensions
senate majority leader mcconnell said
today he has not made a final decision
on how he will vote and will listen to
the arguments when they are presented to
the senate
he must go he is a clear and present
danger
to the nation that we all love
a vote to impeach would further divide
this nation
three out of nevada's four
representatives voted yes to
impeach president trump congressman
amade voted no cbs evening news will
have much more on this
in less than 30 minutes